hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about a type of auger used in
microbiology labs and hospital labs that
is called hectone enteric auger it's
named for the hectone institute where it
was developed
now
a heck auger can be abbreviated in a few
different ways some people will call it
heck auger
a-k-h-e-h-e-a so depending on where
you're working there might be different
abbreviations this auger is both
selective and differential i'll explain
exactly what that means as we go through
it but basically selective means it
allows some things to grow and not other
things and differential means that what
does grow will grow with different
colors or characteristics that allows
you to differentiate between one type of
organism and another growing on the heck
plate now specifically
this type of auger is used to recover
two
major enteric pathogens and those are
salmonella
and
shigella
so these will be recovered
uh from certain samples uh people may be
looking at like food samples or water
samples think about a public health
specialist epidemiologist they're trying
to figure out if areas are contaminated
by
uh by enteric pathogens um also like
patient specimens could be tested so
like fecal samples from a patient who is
suspected to have a salmonella or
shigella infection uh their fecal
samples could be tested with heck auger
now salmonella and shigella are both
gram
negatives
now i have another video on
gram-positive bacteria and gram-negative
bacteria on their cell wall structures
on what makes gram-negative and
gram-positive bacteria different so if
you need to please check that video out
this heck auger contains a few different
things
so it contains bile salts and dyes that
inhibit that other gram type the gram
positive
bacteria
so the bile salts and dyes these are
present actually in a lot of different
agar anything that's trying to select
four gram negative cells and inhibit
gram-positive cells will often include
these things
excuse me so this is where the
selectivity
comes in
for this auger it is selecting four gram
negative bacteria and selecting against
gram positive bacteria heck auger also
contains three different sugars and some
indicators to support fermentation
remember that fermentation can be used
by a variety of bacteria
and can have
different types of acid products
that will change the ph of the medium
when those acids are produced as those
sugars are fermented and that allows
indicators to show like a color change
so
this will
allow
differentiation of enteric bacteria
remember that enteric is referring here
to
those bacteria
that
are found
in the intestines
now
these bacteria the ones that can support
fermentation of these sugars
will have a
ph change or cause a ph change that
results in a color change in those
indicators and that will cause sort of
yellow or salmon colored colonies so
sometimes it's kind of yellow
yellowish orange pinkish that kind of
salmon color
and that means positive for fermentation
now this is where i really want you to
listen up
because
if
a person has taken you know one of these
types of samples and they've placed it
on heck auger and something has grown
and they see salmon-colored colonies
that indicate fermentation of these
sugars has happened
that is actually
expected from like a like an intestinal
sample
because this actually allows this is
cool i think it allows
differentiation between
what we would consider
uninteresting enterics things like e
coli that's present in the guts of many
people
and often is not pathogenic so
it can differentiate between
basically non-pathogenic enteric
bacteria
and shigella and salmonella because
shigella and salmonella will not
ferment these sugars and will not create
these salmon-colored colonies rather
i'll actually switch colors here rather
shigella and salmonella
will appear
green
or in the case of
salmonella potentially black and i'll
explain that in a second
so we'll appear um green or kind of
greenish black
in one case and alkalize the auger which
will turn it
blue
so remember alkali means raise the ph
become more basic
and that will create
a blue color from one of those
indicators so this is where the
differential comes in you know the
uninteresting enterics that are
non-pathogenic or that are not
salmonella and not shigella maybe this
kind of salmon color whereas shigella
and salmonella will
at least initially be green and cause
that auger to change to kind of a bluish
color
so now let's talk about what else hector
auger contains and that is sulfur
sources and indicators for
hydrogen
sulfide
production
okay so for hydrogen sulfide production
when hydrogen sulfide is produced
you can either get colonies that are
entirely black
or that still have this green color i
was telling you about but have black
centers so either entirely black
colonies or black centers in those green
colonies mean positive for hydrogen
sulfide production
and so that is a way that salmonella and
shigella can be differentiated between
let's briefly talk about some downsides
to hecton ochre first of all it does not
provide information on all enterics so
there can be
um bacteria in a person's gut
that hectone auger won't tell you
anything about one notable one is
klebsiella which is a pathogen
so if a person is infected with
klebsiella
heptone enteric auger is not going to
allow a doctor to learn about that
klebsiella infection it's really just
when someone is looking for
salmonella or shigella that they're
going to use this hectonentaric auger
another downside of heck auger is that
it does require conformation by other
methods so other biochemical methods
serological tests
pcr-based tests can all confirm what is
suspected
based on growth on heck auger in other
words heck auger is not conclusive
at the species level on its own
so somebody using heck auger is not
going to be able to differentiate
between different species of shigella
between different species of salmonella
between different species of you know
these other enterics that cause the
salmon-colored colonies in order to get
a more specific
uh conformation you really have to
follow up the heck auger with one of
these other tests
and so now let's just summarize the main
observations e coli and other
non-pathogens will generally be
that sort of salmon
or
um kind of
orange yellow
pink
type color
salmonella
will have
black
centers and green colonies or outright
just black colonies shigella
tends to be slightly more
green
than salmonella and it lacks any
black coloration so there's not going to
be any black coloration for shigella
because it doesn't produce hydrogen
sulfide
this is a list of other videos that i
have on my channel so other types of
auger if you're interested in other
types of selective or differential
augers you can check out my videos on
mcconkey auger mannitol salt auger e and
b auger
i also have a lot of videos on different
micro biology tests things like the
catalyze test oxidase test dna tests
that allow differentiation between
different types of bacteria
also i have a lot of videos on different
stains the gram stain the acid fasting
the endospore stain ones that aren't
even listed here the flagellus thing the
endosporosane so i have a bunch of
videos that you might be interested in
checking out if you want to learn more
about how scientists and doctors
detect and differentiate between
different kinds of bacteria please
remember to subscribe
and check out more of my videos hit the
little bell icon to get notifications
and thank you very much as always for
watching biology professor i have
started taking pictures of my finished
boards and putting them in links for you
guys so if you would like a link to the
final board for note-taking purposes
then you can grab that picture
along with pdfs to the rest of my board
notes in the link in the description
below so thanks for watching biology
professor see you next time